welcome to this video yeah this is a new
episode of the chess openings uncovered
serious maybe a serious that some of you
don't even know because I did a couple
of videos three exactly in this series
but it's sort of yeah got to stop
sometime ago and I thought why not do
something new here yeah I'm looking at
one particular opening and trying to get
an overview what's going on there how
does this opening unfold what are the
ideas what are the main points and some
variations yeah to illustrate what's
happening and are we looking at the
nimzo-indian yeah this is an opening
that features very frequently on my
channel in my blitz games simply because
I tested out a couple of lines that I'm
featuring in my upcoming book and also
have it quite often is white the
nimzo-indian is simply very complex
opening that of course arises after if
we put it on the board arises here I
actually came to the or I got this idea
to look at the names are here for this
for this video I got this idea because I
saw a post on Reddit the chess page on
reddit and someone called common list he
posted a question he said I want to play
this opening as black but I have some
questions I understand the idea of c7 c5
sometimes this move c7 c5 blocking
possible double points or d6 and e5
closing the center d6 + e5 but what I
did is the moves d5 have sometimes like
is also playing
with d5 and why doesn't why take on see
if every five I think that opening the
center is good for why because he has
two bishops okay yes more of a strategic
generals teacher question and what I'm
going to do is I want to look at some
lines of this opening and try to explain
what are the ideas behind those some
those palm pushes in the center and the
central formations that can come up so
I'm going to address the questions that
he that he posed but I will do so with
some concrete positions to look at
because those kind of general questions
are very difficult to answer
especially in an opening like the name
zone because the main um advantage of
one main point of the nimzo-indian is
its flexibility this is a very flexible
opening and why because the pawn
structure that black will go to yeah we
will have it's not yet determined what
he's doing with those three first moves
is being very economical night out the
pawn the bishop and he's ready to castle
one move form this is something that is
new times not really yeah appreciated
Black is castling on move four in many
nines for example if white plays Queen
c2
or e3 the move castles is actually the
main continuation this is happening very
early yeah there are only very little
lines and you know in the whole chess
where black is going to castle that
quickly and while doing so me has
developed the bishop and taken some
central influence over the e4 square
that's of course very important feature
black is fighting for you for for the
moment just with pieces it is actually a
common misconception that this is the
whole idea of the nihms Oh to to fight
for the center with pieces sometimes you
you read that and it's just plain wrong
the thing is there are lines in the van
fact there is central influence with
pieces in the initial position
definitely before has covered due to the
Technic only four but in most lines and
the vast majority of lines black will
put pawns in the center it is just
delayed the good thing about this
however is that according to
circumstances according to what why does
flick and decide how to put the pawns
this is a big difference to the Queens
gambit declined that could pop up after
d5 a little different move order it
could also happen after d4 d5 c4 e6 and
then the Knights but here you are
totally fixed to this kind of structure
with the pawn on d5 that you will
maintain very often sometimes you will
take but you have a pawn on d5 you're
not going to put it on d6 it's just on
d5 already and with the nihms oh you're
very flexible in that regard and in some
cases you might never move the D pawn
there are games where this pawn never
moves yeah so what other lines that are
available and how do they yeah how are
the pawn structures connected to them
white really has tried about everything
under the Sun against the against an
Enzo and the two main continuations by
harm this is an opening that does not
have a clearly defined main line in some
openings it is very clear what the
principle approaches let's say if you
take the Kings Indian for example it is
very clear that the classical Kings
Indian is the main line or if you see a
45 it's clear that the ruler PES is
going to be the main line that you and
it will always be the main line probably
in the name so it's not so clear there
are two equally popular moves Queen C 2
and E 3 and they happen with about the
same frequency both are played in about
I need to look it up and looked it up
actually a couple of weeks ago in in
about 30% of the games like in 30% about
30% this case
move in 30% this move and the rest 40%
is kind of distributed with among the
other moves that that can happen I will
look at the two main moves later but
let's just look at the other things that
white can do they're the oldest
continuation against the Newman so
actually I'm probably the oldest is the
move a three the Samish variation named
after fritz same measurement Grandmaster
yeah there's also damage in the Kings
Indiana one known well known name in
chess 3 which is basically said okay I
don't want give me the double pause okay
like it's happy to oblige yeah what is
why it's idea with this isn't this kind
of weird to double the pawns like that
yeah in a way it is it is a very sharp
continuation white is basically saying
goodbye to his pawn structure this is
really weak yeah if we look at this
especially C 4 and C 3 and this is very
important to understand in this double
confirmations in the new zone the
problem is not just that the pawns are
weak it's also that all those squares
are weak that means that when one of
those pawns if one of those pawns going
to fall like the c4 pawn it there's
still a glaring weakness on c4 it's it's
a pawn that's going to get lost but also
a weakness where piece might land the
whole Queen side is basically it's
basically destroyed here for white and
long-term and this is so very important
it also means that in some cases it's
even not a big issue if black is playing
for example well it's not a line that is
particularly great but in general if a
move like d5 happens and there is a
trade there's still a weakness on c4
there's not a pawn there but there might
be a piece on c4 in some cases
like the night could come there and I
could come there it could attack c3 yeah
it means this is a permanently weak
Queen side even if the pawn is not there
anymore on c4
however here in this double confirmation
blacks normal idea to play is to
directly attack those pawns like very
often will avoid the move d5 but will
instead put pressure on this pawn
very often he wants to make sure that
the pawn is never running away
yeah with c5 fixing those pawns this is
actually a point that this poster on
reddit mentioned c75 to block the double
points that's true this is a way of
blocking those pawns and black very
often will get this in Knight to a5 b6
Bishop a6 yeah focusing on its power on
the c4 pawn and very often this pawn
will fall this is a very common plan
against the doubled pawns in the nihms
Oh to be perfectly honest there are not
that many lines that actually feature
this double pawn then the Zima schism
let's say them there all is the core
version of that where white is really
forcing the structure right on move form
5 however you want to come on to see it
and there are not that many other lines
that have the double pole very often
white takes care of that or the capture
is not that attractive for black because
he only rarely wants to take there
unless being kicked with a 3 it's just a
temple a tempo issue yeah in this image
you have a battle that normally looks
like that white is going to push his
center up and black is going to take c4
yeah this is a line that I have played
frequently in my blitz games not because
it is so brilliant for white but it is a
very sharp entertaining line to play
yeah it needs to sometimes complete
chaos and it's just very fun to play on
videos yeah it's very rarely that you
have
boring boring game yeah him like it's
normally playing c5 fixing the double
pawns and attacking the pawns this is
the same age variation there are some
more sub variations but this is the the
general theme of this line white can
also try to improve in a way on this
image in the same is very often white
ultimately wants to build up this big
pawn Center and he can also say okay
a3 I don't need that move I play a3
immediately I want to go
efore fighting for the c-4 square and on
that black has a wide variety of options
he should do something about this efore
idea if he just allows efore and then
sits around he will have a problem
simply because he has no central control
f3 has really moved that signals black
okay he falls coming do something about
it and black has to fight this idea he
can either play d5 this is a case where
d5 makes perfect sense
why well you're striking in the center
and fight from space there in a moment
where White has played the move f3 if
you think of the queen's gambit for
example white very rarely would put a
pawn on a three because it's simply
wrong there it blocks the knight black
is actually trying to open up the
position in a situation where White has
a development problem yeah he's behind
in development that's very important to
see and he will take a long while until
he has casted short
so d5 is totally logical opening up the
position there are other versions of
that idea actually black can also Castle
first and as mentioned casting on before
and after if for looking scary he has to
strike black here this is a kind of only
move situation black will get run over
unless he plays d5 so he has to d5
pushing in the center and breaking up
the center so this is a typical example
of this as they called it at the time
hyper modern approach yeah you
temporarily give white the opportunity
to occupy
the center but then you find it and here
with g5 later c5 black is breaking up
the center leads to a very sharp play
white is behind in development yeah very
very important and black will quite
often get a good attack young really a
good attack against the king if white is
not careful it's a case where over
expanding might happen easily but f3 can
be answered totally differently as
mentioned it is a very flexible opening
that black has c5 is also possible
checking the center this makes also some
sense because the natural move might be
Knight f3 to to kind of support this
pawn but it's not available anymore
so what will push it gaining some space
and TM black again white is threatening
in a way strategically speaking to put
up this big Center with E for Bishop d3
92 and so on he has to do something he
cannot just just sit around and here we
see another key idea that is possible
black can play b5 very aggressively
attacking the center this is actually
the line that I recommend in in my
upcoming book it's it's super aggressive
stuff that attacks the white center
immediately f3 is a sharp move it's a
move that he actually recommended in in
d4 repertoire series produced a while
ago because white also has his chances
it's it's a very principled approach
against against the names oh and black
has various ways to fight it
c5 or d5 was totally different ideas d5
in a more classical way and c5 d 5b v in
gambit style that that breaks down the
center note that after here
if white really is this is greedy and
takes everything we get a fantastic
compensation here with this big pawn
center and here the move f3 looks
entirely ridiculous as white is
completely behind in development black
even coming up with this or if I if you
know what a center the fantastic
position so white cannot even take the
pawn it's not a real pawn sacrifice it's
just very aggressively attacking the
center
yeah those f3 and the Z which is kind of
related also in spirit but here very
often
why does able to avoid the move a three
he sometimes display after d5 for
example white does play a three because
he's simply out of other moves he has to
clarify the situation in the center and
Shia black main line is actually to play
this and then c5 this is a case where
black is some playing d5 and sefa as the
reddit post dimension there are some
some of those cases why is what writes
black doing that him development is
sucky he's better developed night is out
already and he's opening up the center
in a moment where why does kind of
unorganized yeah lose a three looks
kinda weird he has no peace out
and also note that after C takes Knight
takes which is the main line there's
still a weakness here yeah or c4 is a
weak square yeah just the double parts
going away is one thing but there are
still tons of weaknesses left on the
queenside very often actually in those
kind of positions black is allowing this
capture being a pawn down and he says
okay your pawns are so weak yeah I don't
want I will pick them up later now this
is a very valid line for black this is a
three and f3 both of these moves are
kind of ambitious yeah and not very much
focused on development there are also
moves that focus on development 93 for
example is a quite popular nowadays very
natural move puts a piece out where it
belongs yeah actually knight on f3 and
tear again black is super flexible here
in fact is the case where black handle a
putting a pawn in the center for very
long time with b6 in spirit of the
Queen's Indian where you feel chatter
this Bishop here you can actually get
away with not playing d5
see five for quite a while for example
there are lines like this let's say III
the Sham here
bhishan here 94 yeah putting more
pressure here in situ jazz takes and f5
this is a typical approach mixing the
nimzo-indian teams with a little bit of
the dutch yeah with the f5 move here
black will not play c5 or d5 for a long
time probably
yeah d5 not at all and c5 may be in very
rare cases but other than that he is
very content with having this nice piece
on e4 laughter neither three are ever
black also can play c5 there's nothing
wrong with that and go for development
with Knight to c6 or sometimes he can
also use Queen a5 to put pressure on
this night yeah a very flexible there
are many themes that are going to be
mixed for example if white now plays g3
an idea that is it's really popular
nowadays fianchetto in here black has
ideas like capturing creating the Dawa
pawns and play the Queen to a5 yeah here
the pawn will stay on the 7 and very
often we will go for this development
focusing on the weaknesses there are
other ideas though and I'm a book for
example I have this one I'm sorry
Bishop g2 94 increasing the pressure
like that on the c3 Knight after 93 very
often though some Yan on d5 approaches
are going to be applied one reason is
that it is very often as mentioned
connected to the fianchetto and when the
bishop comes to g2 the c4 pawn is more
week and then than usual you know it
makes lots of sentence to concentrate on
this possible double pawn this is
weakness on c4 like of course can play
d5 but this is actually a transposition
to the Queen's Gambit rogozin there are
goals in variation of the Queen's Gambit
very popular nowadays
is a mixture of the Queen's Gambit 'some
and newman's Oh actually yeah so black
is very flexible you can also Castle by
the way and delay his decision here if
he wants to go see if I four or d5
there's also a line Bishop g5 yeah well
white just developed the bishop first
yeah that's an interesting line the
leningrad variation has it it caught and
here in fact black quite often will also
make this double policy three for
example the line that is very popular he
has this check yeah where black is going
to close the center this kind of
formation and create the double pawn
this is another central formation that
is quite frequently seen in the games Oh
a very solid way to play closing the
center and putting the pawns there on
dark squares this is a prime example of
the so-called dark squared strategy
means that you put the pawns on the dark
square c5 d 65 after your Bishop is
exchanged or developed outside of the
pawn chain there are also some lines
where the bishop is still there on
before but you still put those pawns on
the dark squares the idea is that with
the bishop traded this is really the the
most frequent case you have a very sound
pawn structure ports are on dark squares
and you have the light squared Bishop
left so this is a good yeah a good
combination to have you don't have the
bishop on f8 anymore which would be a
bad Bishop yeah sometimes in the Kings
Indian Lex and black suffering from this
kind of formation where he has a bishop
on g7 and it looks at his own pawn and
cannot really get out this is never
happening here you really from the very
GetGo you have a very strategically
sound position you will never have a
truly
long term bad piece yeah okay we can
completely completely
yes screw up the middlegame and put your
Knights in the corners or whatever but
it's nothing that is kind of inherent to
the structure there are some openings
that carry this kind of danger with them
the dark squared bishop in the Kings
engine is an example or the light
squared bishop in the French yes it kind
of can happen yeah and this is not
happening here very much that black will
suffer from a bad bishop simply because
the pawns are already on the right
squares this kind of approach is
happening in some other lines as well we
come to that against the landing-grid
variation this is a very valid approach
Black has some others you know he can
also go for this kind of structure which
it's normally called the nihms Oh Ben
Oni yeah this is a Ben Ben Oni structure
in the modern Ben Oni the bishop is
normally on g7 but yeah it is something
before it's an interesting an
interesting way to play something that I
have in mind well book as well there are
many many possibilities note that after
Bishop g5 Black is not so often playing
d5 why is that yeah the reason is that
if you compare this to the f3 variation
earlier here this f3 is not been played
so what can develop very fluently yeah
there is some very little incentive for
black to put it on c-5m because White's
development is not hampered and in this
structures it's not so clear what you
will do with this kind of pin it's um
sometimes can be a problem in the
LightSquared center this pin that the
bishop is on before this combination is
it's not it's not so or so easy to play
it's not a terribly bad move but it is
quite uncommon kind of quite uncommon to
do it yeah this one a couple of less
frequently seen lines but the main lines
really what about the main lines yeah
let's start with the
III as mentioned played in more than 30
percent of all nimzo-indian games the e3
line is called the Rubinstein variation
named after the famous yeah they don't
they didn't have the Grandmaster title
back then really in our modern sense but
let's call him a grandmaster Rubinstein
and he invented let's say or he
popularized this replied to the names oh
he threw what is the idea it's a very
very sound move what it wants to do is
it wants to get the Kings are developed
finally yeah we shouldn't forget if you
look at the initial position of the
nihms Oh black is ready to Castle black
smooth and white is still a couple of
hooves away from that he needs one pawn
move and Knight move a bishop move and
then he can Castle black is actually
head in development and it will be
canceled much quicker that sounds a bit
abstract because the position at the
moment is kind of close there is no
direct clash of both sides but it can
become very very relevant if white is
kind of neglecting his development of
the King side even further there are
some cases where black really gets quick
attacks based on this fact and we will
see some some of those lines when we
look at the Queen c2 variation Queen c2
is the other main line which in fact
does not accelerate the kingside
development III preparing development
Bishop out Night Out castling the other
idea of III is different white might
also play the move Knight G to e2 or
Knight to e2 F there's no G - e -
because of the pin Knight to e2
to cover let's say the c3 Knight and be
able to recapture with the night which
would be very convenient yeah avoiding a
double horn once is free while getting
developed on the kingside this is
another idea what in fact has those two
basic development plans after e3 putting
the knight on f3 Bishop d3 castling yeah
so let's say this is one basic plan for
example if we just look at the white
moves I had to put out something for
black this is one basic plan the other
plan is to put the 9 3 2 this can happen
after there should be three yeah and
then castling or it can happen
immediately on move 5 these are the two
basic plans and white has in any case
white can always play a three later by
the way yeah for example here you could
play a three and then we would transpose
to a damage this is always an option in
fact a way that that I usually play the
same as if I'm going for that and in my
in my blitz games yeah III mostly a
developing move it looks like it helped
us the bishop that's true for the moment
it does but this is very rarely a
problem because in most lines this
bishop will come to life and we'll see
how this is going to happen after e3
Black has a wide range of options there
are many lines and this is a very
positive feature this flexibility that I
mentioned gives black so many options to
choose from that this opening can be a
very long-term companion for for a
player because you you play it and you
can very often just change some sub
variants of variations that you're
probably not content with yeah there you
play one particular line against the
three and then you discover okay this is
not so much to my liking then you you
don't need to discard the whole opening
you just switch a little
suck variation yeah it's not like you
need to buy a new car every day in case
of yeah just just one tie as a little
hole and this is in this opening is just
the case as well you just you can just
and put a little thing to the repair
shop and you still can use it after you
three what are blacks options he has to
choose a center of formation
note that black if you wanted he could
capture on c3 but this is very rarely
done in this particular situation
because White's development is
completely flexible there for example
white can still play like that and then
put out efore f4 and so on it's a little
bit like as image variation where white
was not forced is wrong but he hasn't
spent a move on a3 this is rarely done
there are cases where black captures
voluntarily in particular in particular
a variation that is named after German
Grandmaster Rob tube now we come to that
this is this is a very specific case and
very important to understand the
difference by taking here is not so
great we will see that when we look at
the Huebner variation
um yeah after you three black has has
mentioned many options one option is to
play b6 combining the pin here with the
kingside over the queenside fianchetto
we actually saw something earlier that
can also come up like that
this kind of idea very valid after b6
white can also go here and ask like what
is going to do about this situation in
fact 92 is nowadays considered as some
pretty good reply to be six because here
white quite often will get the bishop
pair without any concession this is
important to understand with bishop
before black very often gives up the
bishop in cases and he needs to have
some kind of compensation for that the
bishop pam is almost
comparable to admit to something
material enchants like a pawn it's not
that much worth like a pond but it is
something long-term and you don't want
to give it up for nothing you want to
have some structural concession from
white you want to have better
development or you want to have a very
flexible sound structure and here for
example if you look at this line like
this like say Bishop out check and black
takes this is simply not a completely
satisfactory outcome of the opening for
black he has given up the bishop pair
without a structural concession and
white will relatively quickly get his
kings had developed yeah
very often black has to do something now
to to play in the center yeah like
something with g5 not not right now at
London's a piece to Queen a forward yes
to do something in the center now and
you shouldn't just give up the bishop
pair like that this is even a funny line
that is crap option and nowadays looks
kind of exotic but it shows that you
really don't want to take on c3 yet and
allow the recapture with the night in
fact I believe that practically all
lines where black will capture against a
90 to set up and why can we capture with
a night I think they're all not 100%
precise yeah you should should avoid
that as black
yeah b6 is a viable line um black can
also play c5 or you can play with d5
there is a bit of a difference if you
can scale off first or play c5 or d5
immediately but I don't want to want to
go that much let's just say black
castles first you have to do that in any
case and let's say we start here white
plays Bishop d3 if we start with this
development plan here black has to
choose you can go with a d5 based setup
or whether the c5 base setup you can
combine both modes of course but let's
say you want to put it on d5 after this
very often it will unfold like that
Knight to f3 Knight 3 2 is also possible
as mentioned not to have 3 c5 castles
yeah this is a case where black has put
our pawns on c5 and d5 and our post a on
reddit asked ok why does black do that
the reason is that why not put pawns in
the center it's not a bad thing
the Queen's Gambit for example where it
is done it's not a bad opening what
black did here what he started with
bishop before but there is no particular
reason why not to play c5 or d5 now we
fight for the center with our pawns and
we have the bishop outside on before
note that compared to the Queens gambit
declined white here has a bishop on c1
you know this is kind of the concession
that what was forced in and not forced
but what made on move for for getting
the Kings I developed quickly you
temporarily have the bishop on c1 yeah
black and in fact has a wide range of
options the most popular way to play
this nowadays is to to trade him in play
b6 in line that is normally called the
cap of variation cup of plate this very
very often with very good results and he
actually got this out of the nihms oh
and also out of the car con yeah you can
get it out of the panel
caro-kann and i want to show the
particular move order but it can happen
yeah here we see another transformation
black has cleared the center and now
intends to put the bishop on b7 he now
went for playing against the isolated
queen pawn very valid option there are
other ways to play black can also play
Knight to 6 just development and here
this kind of center can can pop up white
can force the the trade on c3 ok black
can't play Bishop a5 but that's a
different story
yeah here we have
a different version of the pawn
structure here for example we have a
case where black is allowing this
capture on d5 so allowing white to get
rid of his doubled pawns but this is not
the end of the board like he has has
other benefits by taking for example
this problem has been solved for him
yeah so it's a trade off white got rid
of his double pawn a black card is
Bishop out possibly also here black
sometimes has the option of playing c4 b
v a5 pushing his four against free
majority on the Queen side the d5 c5
setups against the Rubinstein actually
the most popular setups now now nowadays
you just put both pawns there a
different way to play it is associated
with the move c5 where black is not
playing d5 we will see how this unfolds
Knight f3 Knight to c6 castles and now
an interesting way to play and one main
feature of my proposed repertoire in
this and this upcoming book is this the
so called Huebner variation I already
mentioned that this is again a line that
strives for the dark squared central set
up pawns on dark squares after the
Bishop has been traded the very basic
way to do it is like that this is the
old main line of the Huebner variation
that was played back in the early 70s
for example in the very famous v match
game between Boris Spassky and and Bobby
Fischer where Fischer won a very nice
very nice game with the black pieces
with a very ingenious concept that was
really revolutionary at the time he
played like that and 96's was a move
that was completely
yeah blowing people's minds at the time
nowadays this is very well-known this
kind of idea but at the time it looked
crazy that black would allow this kind
of structure but it is a very very valid
for back okay I don't want to go into
this detail what is the point of this
pawn structure okay black is very solid
with this bishop on the on the right
color complex and here's ideas to play
on the flanks yeah black wants to play
f5 sometimes or in some specific cases
you can also play for b5 this has to be
carefully considered of course because
it trades away the the double point
note that the double pawn at the moment
is not such a big issue for white it
cannot easily be attacked this is also
the reason why black is going to e7 and
not to a5 and it's a very important
thing to understand the most Knight a5
attacking this someone we can pawn is
more appropriate in cases where the
center is still fluid with a closed
center here this is not that problematic
because the the maximum that black can
do in terms of pressure is b6 Bishop a6
like this let's say me and let's put
something out um I can't play 3 b6 this
is not this is not making much sense but
I just want to see the show either the
actual idea this is the best that I can
do and we can easily protect it like
this or sometimes one can also do this
maneuver while keeping this protected
and this is not leading to much in the
in the same issue for example there is
no close center there black sometimes
can even put a bishop here a rook on c8
and threaten to capture on C on d4 to
put more pressure here and this is not
not happening in the Huebner variation
here black absolutely should go to e7
the reason is that very often the king
side is the main battleground white will
try to gain space on the King side quite
often with a deer slug let's say G 3 F 4
at some moment
and black is also playing with this f5
idea sometimes the knight can also go to
g6 you know this is a situation where
the center is completely closed and play
will be on the flanks the Huebner
variation can also be played a little
bit differently with white what can also
avoid the movie for you can play things
like that 92 and then black plays 95
here we have a situation that where
where the original posting on reddit
said ok why it's why it's not taking or
exchanging on e5 and the reason is and I
probably should explain it with this
position if you capture on on CF every 5
in this kind of situation you really
don't accomplish that much with white
especially this Bishop stays pretty yeah
pretty sorry piece it's not doing very
much and in terms of opening the
position the problem here with white is
that you're not going to open the Queen
side ever because there is no no way of
breaking it up you have black is just
putting out b6 and it's stable as a rock
iam there is no kind of dynamism here
and the only way to really open up this
kind of position is on the Kings side
and you rather want to open the Kings
side with the pawns being here as this
defines a very clear advantage in space
for you you at least have the advantage
in space without those points that is
not happening the only reason we're
white ever would want to trade yemen is
a situation where white could plant a
knight on d5 this is not so easy but you
can try that yeah this was shown in some
classic games by Mohammed Winnick you
know actually I could maybe I have
featured one of but winix cams and in
the in the middle game strategy serious
sport vinik against Jehovah I think
where it puts the knight on d5 in the
scandal structure other than that the
capture is very young very unpromising
actually there are other situations
where the center can be opened for
example after 92 which is a move that is
played quite often my white the ideas to
ultimately still use the F pawn 5 there
are situations where the center will get
opened for example here white can ignore
this pressure on d4 by playing a move
like group B 1 and here for example
black should be very reluctant to grab
this pawn as this is really opening up
the bishops yeah what the exchange on
see if I what if F it's not doing it
this is a fantastic position for White's
Bishop p.m. yeah so in the in the
Huebner you want to close the center as
black keep it closed play on the flanks
this is some yeah a big part of my my
repertoire that I described in the book
white can also as mentioned develop with
this kind of information here black of
course does not want to trade on c3 as
this gives up the bishop pair without
any structural compensation yeah and who
can I at least give him the double pawn
but this is not happening here here
blacks best is actually switched back to
a d5 setup where we will get again an
isolated queen pawn position yeah this
is just like the cap of variation before
but there the night was an f3 kid is on
e to a little bit of a difference but
the strategic themes are very very
comparable the other thing is white can
of course as mentioned cover this c3
Knight and here black has to think about
his setup very very cautiously because
if he is simply ignoring this idea let's
say he plays c5 a380 takes this is
simply not a good position
black it's just like that I know this
has been played by some some decent
players some I even cap off in the 70s
but nowadays this is kind of it is kind
of clear that you should not really play
like that as black you give up the the
bishop pair for no clear compensation
and note that here the night only to
actually clocks up White's development
the night has to move again like here or
here then the bishop moves then you
castle and with the capture this just
better sped up White's development very
much you go Bishop out and castles next
um what black normally does is he
switches back to a d5 approach basically
saying okay I'm going to play like I do
in the Queen's Gambit and I'm just
retreating my Bishop to e7 or to g6 both
possible and you're claiming okay
I play a Queen's Gambit kind of setup
and you have played III a3 and 922 and
you have the bishop on c1 isn't this
kind of bad in a Queen's Gambit yes it
is and this is the reason why this kind
of setup is not not that great for what
he can do that it's not like his words
or anything it's just a position to play
but it's nothing with scarce black very
much the motivation for putting d5 out
is simply the case that in this kind of
setup White's positions and White's
pieces are simply not very well
positioned to fight for the center you
really want a knight on f3 and only two
yeah white can try all kinds of things
they're like taking and g3 but
ultimately black has a very healthy game
can put the bishop our two can play c5
the right moment if he wants yeah this
is how it is played I can add a further
idea rook e8 which is my move here in
this position the idea being to even
retreat all the way back to f8 preserve
this Bishop and then striking in the
center later it's also interesting way
to play
yeah this is e33 and ultimately there is
the classical variation Queen c2
sometimes called Kappa Blancas variation
but classical as the the most common
name with Queen c2 why does some
announcing his intention to play a3
getting the bishop pair without having
any structural structural damage so this
is kind of he wants to have the best of
all worlds in a way what it does however
it neglects development yeah of the king
side especially so here black has
various ideas and some ideas are even
very very aggressive try to use this
development advantage for example you
can go d5 here's again a case where d5
is a move and the ideas that after Wyatt
is grabbing the bishop pair black can
strike very aggressively in the center
for example there are lines like that I
just want to show you one where lines
like that where black is getting out his
pieces very quickly and white is not
even close to being cancelled this is
very very sharp stuff where black is
really going for gambit play yeah this
is really a very aggressive plain black
has various options of that kind he can
play this early d5 he can start with
castling and check play with the d5 firm
later try to really open up the center
very quickly there are various gambit
ideas here for example there are also
ideas like that
the black is all of a sudden pushing in
the middle he has castle already he's
very quick with his pieces while white
is completely sleeping here on their own
the King's idea isn't done anything here
so this is in some way a risky line
Queen situated evolved some risk
sometimes yeah your development is not
great
there is this school of thought that
black should try to yeah open up the
center quickly this is usually reached
with the move d5 or castles and d5 there
are other ideas black can also play c-5m
attacking again with this pawn the big
difference is that here white can very
nicely take this is not often in options
in other cases because of the possible
triple pawn if we just fall as long as
long comparison sake let's say something
like this here
c5 what wouldn't want to take here
probably because check well this is very
ugly right those pawns are very very
vulnerable in the Queen c2 line and
after c5 you can very safely capture
because just your structure here is very
sound black will weak take yeah any
capture here check can be answered by
Queen takes yeah and here after Bishop
takes we get very often a position like
that where DN C pawn have been traded
yeah some of quite a flexible setup for
black but it's not clear if it's really
enough to equalize that's one option
that black has another option is that
black says okay I'm going to give you
the best bishop pair but I'll be
flexible there are various ways to do
that as well black can't start with them
after Queen c2 can start with with
castling and after this check he can put
out his pawns in a very flexible way for
example he can play something like this
b6 you shouldn't be 7 this just show you
something this kind of thing yeah Black
has a very sound structure yes no
weaknesses whatsoever and he stays very
flexible with his pawns he can at any
given moment
go c5 d5 or a 5 according to what white
is doing you can react accordingly very
often this
typical for the names oh that the
flexibility means that you can have look
okay why doing and then you kind of do
the right thing against it all the time
which is not does not mean that it is
passive it's just flexible you can react
in a way that fits wide set up the
flexible approach is also something or
getting a sound structure let's say and
being flexible it's also something that
I have in my book what I'm proposing is
this line the Zurich variation which is
a bit comparable to what we saw before
black here also gives up the the bishop
pair without having any structural
compensation but what he gets is he gets
a very healthy structure for example it
can happen like that I just put
something out and it's fairly typical
yeah like this is this kind of thing
yeah this is again the dark-squared
Center yeah here we don't have c5 plate
yeah but other than that it kind of
reminds us of this this set up in the
Huebner
with g6e five plate and again it's play
on the flanks black wants to play f5 if
possible sometimes you can strike with
c6 sometimes with b5 not happening that
often but there are cases where this is
possible very often
f5 would be the principled way to do it
yeah here white enjoys more space and
here's the bishop pair but what black
has it's very healthy long-term you
don't have a bad piece your dark square
bishop is gone and you can play those
those flank maneuvers f5 or Knight h v
2f form a positive thing for black is
said this is very easy to play I mean we
have very little concrete lines that you
that you need to learn this is why I'm
it shows this some form for my
repertoire work black
also after Queen c2 has some some rare
options
yeah like d6 or b6 yeah for example b6
is a funny move that actually allows you
for but then will initiate some concrete
counter play here in the center with c5
c6 recently gained some popularity it's
not a very very mainstream approach
white can also be flexible for example
after castles he does not have to play a
three but he can also play Knight f3
which again gives black choices c5 d5
it's it's all possible an interesting
moment here after Casas is to move efore
yeah this is some sharp option and again
d5 is played showing that you cannot
allow white to give the full center
without striking at it yeah this is
comparable to the f3 follower and here
queen is on c2 instead of the pawn you
want to fight against the center here
with the pawns and and break and break
the center up yeah the nihms Oh is a
very good opening to happen the black
repertoire because of its great
flexibility and as you have seen there
are very many options and structures
that that black can go for it's also a
good opening actually for the white
player to go into because of the
complexities it is very rarely a
completely dull position there's often
some kind of imbalance going on yeah you
have the bishop pair for forward
structure or you have you as white have
gotten the bishop pair but you're behind
in development these kind of things
they're always leading to two good
interesting games so I can really
recommend to think about playing the
nihms oh well scholars actually it's a
also a good thing for white as mentioned
yeah I hope you enjoyed this overview of
some ideas and concepts of the
nimzo-indian and I'm going to
you do on and off some episodes of the
series yeah other openings to be
explored that's a wide range I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching